conference the president of the European
commission Ursula of underline
[Applause]
thank you very much fellow leaders
excellencies ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure to be back at globsec you had a
very successful conference already so
that's very good where it is spreading
and I'm very glad that and honored that
I have the opportunity today to speak to
you
now the war against Ukraine we have
discussed it in these last two days but
we are discussing it since 15 months now
is a pivotal moment for Europe
and we must meet this moment
it is of course a blatant attack
against the principles of the U.N
Charter
principles that we have collectively
signed up to
but it is also a war
against our values
and the war against the idea of a United
and the free Europe
for the first time
in our history
a country is under attack because of its
desire to be part of the European family
it is Ukraine's Sovereign decision
and the clarity expressed the clarity of
the express will of the Ukrainian people
to embrace our unions values
and in doing so
they are also fighting for our freedom
and for our values
the democracy
the rule of law free speech
the freedom to determine your own
destiny
that is what Ukraine is fighting for
and that is
what President Putin is trying to
extinguish
resident Putin is trying to destroy the
work of peace
that we have built together since the
end of the second world war and later
the fall
of the Iron Curtain
and this ladies and gentlemen
this is the origin of this world
here at globsec I understand you have
been discussing the causes of this war
so let me be very clear
Russia started this unprovoked and
unjustified War
without cause it invaded Ukraine to wipe
out the country from the map
and Russia
refuses to accept Ukraine
as an independent country
but Ukraine's will to fight and to be
free has amazed the world
Ukraine's know
which with iron clad certainty where
they belong to
the Ukrainian people have four years
being The Architects of Ukraine's move
towards the European Union
and they have proven that courage and
that determination time and again
never can we match the sacrifice and The
Bravery of the Ukrainian people
but we can and we must stand firmly by
their side for as long as it takes
the immediate need
you know it
is the military assistance
to sustain the efforts of the Ukrainian
Armed Forces
and this is why we have just proposed an
ammunition production Act
we want to push our defense industry to
ramp up production
of badly needed 155 and 152 millimeters
artery artillery shells
and those who can should provide
long-range artillery and weapon systems
that can help Ukraine level the
battlefield Gap in range to the invading
forces
our support is also needed for military
training of Ukrainian forces
the member states are doing a lot
and we at European level we are doing
our fair share too
so by the end of the year
we will have trained 30
000 servicemen and service women
my second thought on Ukraine
there is much discussion of Peace plans
and ceasefires
above all there must be one principle
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine
so together with Ukraine we want a just
peace
one that does not reward the aggressor
but one that upholds the principles of
the UN Charter and the ukrainians
people's right
to be the masters of their own future
president zielinski is very clear on
that
a ceasefire
resulting in a frozen conflict will not
bring lasting peace
after all a ceasefire was in place after
2014 and we know what happened to that
Arrangement last February when Russia
invaded Ukraine
a ceasefire would be inherently unstable
and destabilize the region along the
contact line
nobody would invest or rebuild
and the conflict could flare up again at
any time
no
a just peace must result
in the withdrawal of the Russian forces
and their equipment from the territory
of Ukraine
president zelenski has come forward with
a peace formula
that we wholeheartedly support
everyone of his 10 points is based on
the U.N Charter
or in U.N resolutions
and he has invited countries around the
world to join in
and to build on the peace formula
so that our starting point for peace is
the rules-based order
a just piece for Ukraine
must also be a lasting one
and to be a lasting peace for Ukraine
it must be strengthened into vital ways
the first is
ensuring the long-term security of
Ukraine
I welcome ongoing discussions on how
Ukraine's security can be guaranteed
and there are different models and
historical examples that can be used
a collection of such guarantees by
like-minded States
can offer what some have called
deterrence by denial
in other words providing Ukraine with
the military equipment
fortify itself
against Russian attacks in the future
and what's important is
that at the end
there's clarity
clarity
that Ukraine's friends will be there for
the Long Haul for Ukraine security
such an arrangement with security
guarantees will need to be accompanied
by a broader framework of Ukraine's
Democratic reforms
to further strengthen
existing checks and balances and here
Ukraine's path towards joining our Union
will play a fundamental role
although everyone knew
that we are embarking on a challenging
Journey
we have given Ukraine candidate status
rightly so
now we must be by their side every step
of the way
fact is
that even as they fight for their
survival
ukrainians are passing crucial reforms
to strengthen their democracy it's
amazing to see that
Ukraine keeps advancing towards our
Union Against All Odds despite this
atrocious War
and we will keep doing our part
to bring Ukraine much closer
and much faster towards a just and
Lasting peace
today
there is a new awareness inside the
European Union
and that's the second point I want to
address
we finally realize
that it is not enough to just wait for
our friends outside the union to move
closer to us
it is not enough to say that the door is
open
we must also take responsibility to
bring the aspiring members of our Union
much closer to us
the shock waves sent by Putin's war of
aggression
have also reached the six Western Balkan
countries
but this has only brought us closer
together
we extended to the Western Balkans the
very same solidarity measures that we
have taken inside our Union
we've supported vulnerable households
against high energy costs
we're building new infrastructure to
reduce the Western Balkans dependency
on Russian fossil fuels
and this practical cooperation has run
in parallel
with progress on the EU path
recent tensions are of course concerning
I call on all sides to step away from
confrontation
and to take measures to restore calm
but today I want to present a new
initiative to seize this important
moment in the region
it is a new growth plan for the Western
Balkans
we want to build on the progress
achieved in the recent month
but we also want to bring some of the
benefits of EU membership
to the people of Western Balkans already
today
the gross plan we are proposing today is
built on four pillars
first
to bring the Western Balkans closer to
the EU single Market
second to deepen Regional economic
integration
third to accelerate fundamental reforms
and forced to increase pre-accession
funds
to a certain extent this is a new
approach to the European Union we do not
only ask our partners to take new steps
towards us
we also take a big step towards them
our shared goal is to speed up their
Journey towards the European Union
so let me introduce these four points
very briefly
for all countries that joined the
European Union in the last two decades
access to the single Market
has been the main driver of economic
success
but countries that are already on a
promising path towards the European
Union
should also benefit from the single
Market
for example
the Western Balkans could join our
digital single Market in areas such as
e-commerce
and cyber security
we could facilitate our trade and goods
and payments
I want our single Market to be a driver
of change not only for countries that
have already joined the family
but also for those who are still on
their way
this closer association with our single
Market
should go hand in hand with a common
regional market
a common regional market is crucial to
an up the the enormous economic
potential of the region and it is
crucial to make the Western Balkans more
attractive for European investors
and if based on EU rules and standards
this common regional market can also
help
accelerate the accession to the European
Union
we want to offer to the Western Balkans
some of the advantages of membership in
advance
but of course this also means that
certain requirements of membership
also have to be met in advance
some of the reforms that are part of the
accession process
are key for investors confidence
just think about building an independent
and efficient judiciary
ensuring sound public procurement
stepping up the fight against corruption
or think about the whole energy Market
the Western Balkan region has a huge
potential
to diversify away from Russian fossil
fuels
but it needs to increase energy
efficiency
it needs to step up diversification to
like-minded Partners
and of course it needs massive
investment in the deployment of
renewable energy
so the Western Balkans can achieve both
they can achieve energy independence
from Russia
and closer alignment with the European
Union to speed up accession
my final point is straightforward
We Stand ready to support Western
Balkans with increased pre-accession
funding
I think it has to be
there's a dire need of investment in the
western Balkans
and these investments will make people's
lives better and they will also smooth
the way into our Union
so for this reason we should increase
the resources dedicated to the Western
Balkans
I think this four-point plan
is just the right offer for the Western
Balkans at the right time
in trouble times
ladies and gentlemen
history is on the move
Putin wanted to grab Ukraine for Russia
he calculated
that the European Union would just
accept it
he was so wrong
instead
Ukraine resisted bravely and is beating
him back
and we in Europe rightly
and steadfastly stand with Ukraine
we are meeting the pivotal moment in
history
and we must stay the course
Ukraine will emerge stronger from this
war
huge crowds are waving European flags in
Moldova and Georgia
whether yearning for place in our
European Union Burns resolutely
the Western Balkans and the union are
getting closer and closer
this is the moment to seize
to forge a more united Europe
Long Live Europe thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you for having us here we invite
everybody to stay in your seats for our
next session with two additional Prime
foreign